last year a Canadian doctor named Joshua
Tapper was able to authorize the killing
of a 23 year old man named Keanu and why
was Keanu kill according to the sub
stack Common Sense Kiana was depressed
he was diabetic and he had lost Vision
in one eye and on top of that he quote
didn't have a girlfriend on those
grounds alone the doctor authorized the
state to kill Keanu there are many more
stories like this there's Amir farsood
who was approved for maid because he was
homeless there is the Army veteran
Christine Gauthier who was told by the
Canadian government to consider
euthanasia rather than endure the weight
for a stair lift in her home and so on
many cases like this now this is
eugenics it's the kind of thing the
medical community thought long and hard
about after World War II doctors
wondered you know how do we make sure
that medicine is never again used to
kill the weakest and least desirable
members of society well doctors no
longer asked that question
Eugenics is making a comeback